[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis ein schönen guten Abend und
willkommen zu einer neuen Woche für den
sportmitarbeit Katja streso schönen
guten Abend und wir beginnen mit einer
unerwarteten Einigung
brexit Kompromiss zu Nordirland im
Streit um den vermeintlich unlösbaren
Status der britischen Provinz finden EU
und Großbritannien nun wohl doch einen
Weg
ein Jahr nach der Zeitenwende Rede des
Kanzlers wie der ukraine-krieg
Energieversorgung Preise und die
Ausstattung der Bundeswehr verändert hat
und Druck auf die öffentlichen
Arbeitgeber mit Warnstreiks in vielen
Bereichen wollen die Gewerkschaften den
Bund und die Kommunen zu einem besseren
Angebot bewegen
über Jahre hatten sich die Europäische
Union und Großbritannien vollkommen
verhakt bei der Frage wie man bei dem
brexit-regelungen mit Nordirland umgeht
vor wenigen Stunden haben
eu-kommissionschefin von der Leyen und
der britische Premier sunak nun eine
Einigung verkündet und das war das
Problem beim brexit hätte es zwischen
der Republik Irland EU und Nordirland
nicht mehr EU eigentlich eine feste
Grenze mit Zollkontrollen geben müssen
das wollte aber niemand auch um den
alten Konflikt zwischen Katholiken und
Protestanten nicht wieder anzufachen der
Kompromiss damals für Nordirland galten
die Regeln des EU-Binnenmarktes weiter
aber dafür gab es eine Zollgrenze auf
hoher See ein großes Hindernis für den
innerbritischen Handel was ich jetzt
ändert zeigt Andreas Stamm
eine Reise nach London für
EU-Spitzenpolitiker seit dem brexit eine
Qual ganz anders zeigt sich am Mittag
die kommissionspräsidentin glücklich
sein sie erklären Ursula von der Leyen
und der britische Premier sunak nach
monatelang Verhandlungen sei der Streit
um das nordirland-protokoll beilgt
Königreich und die EU hatten in der
Vergangenheit so ihre Schwierigkeiten
miteinander aber wir sind alliierte
Handelspartner Freunde in unseren
Beziehungen ist das der Beginn eines
neuen Kapitels
dieser Beginn nennt sich Winzer Rahmen
Vereinbarung benannt nach dem Ort
bekannt vor allem als Residenz des
Königs eine Wahl wohl nicht zufällig die
Pro britischen Unionisten in Nordirland
an den bislang Einigungsversuche
scheiterten verehren den König als
Symbol der britischen Einheit der
Kompromiss sieht vor das waren die von
der britischen Insel nach Nordirland
geliefert und dort verkauft nicht mehr
kontrolliert werden anders als Produkte
die weiter nach Irland in die EU gehen
zudem wird die nordirische mehr und
Steuer wieder in London festgesetzt der
Europäische Gerichtshof bleibt
allerdings letztinstanz sollte es zu
Streitigkeiten über Nordirland als Teil
des eu-bindenmarkt kommen und das
Regionalparlament in Belfast erhält ein
Mitspracherecht bei relevanten EU
Gesetzesvorhaben
Zugeständnisse die Brüssel lange als
unmöglich bezeichnete doch mit sunak
heißt es gäbe es endlich wieder einen
vertrauenswürdigen und
lösungsorientierten Partner
ist oder der Kampf gegen den Klimawandel
wir haben so viel gemeinsam der kämpfen
für die gleichen Werte stehen auf
derselben Seite Schulter an Schultern
für von der Leyen ist die Arbeit getan
es folgte ein Tee mit König Charles auf
Schloss Windsor für sonac beginnt die
noch härtere Wegstrecke die brexit
Hardliner in seiner Partei und in
Nordirland zu überzeugen den Deal
abzusehen
und vorschloss Wunder steht für uns
Hilke Petersen Hilke die Einigung kommt
ihr wirklich ziemlich überraschend was
hatten dazu geführt dass sich EU und
Großbritannien so plötzlich aufeinander
zu bewegt haben
der Tag hier in Winsor war komplett
davon geprägt das Ursula von der Leyen
die angereist war richtig sunak ganz
eindeutig helfen wollte dieses
sogenannte windsor-rahmen diese
Rahmenvereinbarung durchzubringen und
die EU hat auch Interesse wieder näher
an die Nordiren heranrücken hier im
Schloss in Winzer hinter mir traf sich
Ursula von der Leyen dann noch mit King
Charles zum Tee auch das ist sehr
symbolhaft und die Pressekonferenz der
beiden sonak und von der Leyen war eine
einzige Scham offensives wurde gelächelt
und gezwinkert
nun aber ist sie wieder abgereist Ursula
von der Leyen und regisse nackt wird
jetzt die Aufgabe haben die heiklen
Punkte an diesem winterrahmen
Vereinbarung durchzubringen gegen die
brexit Hardliner vor allem die in
Nordirland
danke schön Herr Petersen
genau ein Jahr ist es her das Kanzler
Scholz im Bundestag eine Rede hielt in
der einen historischen Einschnitt
feststellte und auf große Veränderungen
einschwur der russische Angriffskrieg
hatte da gerade begonnen und scholz
sagte
wir erleben eine Zeitenwende
und das bedeutet die Welt danach
ist nicht mehr dieselbe wie die Welt
davor
ja und in der Tat ist viel geschehen
besonders für Energie gegen die Preise
durch die Decke und bei der Bundeswehr
stieg der Bedarf an Ausrüstung hat die
Regierung das alles gut bewältigt nein
sagt die Opposition Thomas Reichert
Zeiten Wände bedeutet in Deutschland vor
allem dies die Bundeswehr danach ist
nicht mehr dieselbe wie die davor so ist
zumindest das Ziel Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius soll dafür sorgen dass das
Militär angesichts der Bedrohung durch
Putin wieder verteidigungsfähig wird der
Minister wie auch der Bundeswehrverband
finden ein Sondervermögen alleinreiche
dafür nicht es brauche Milliarden mehr
im regulären Verteidigungshaushalt jetzt
sind wir hoffentlich aufgewacht und ich
sag bewusst nicht wieder einschlafen wir
haben eine Dekade an Bedrohungen wir
müssen wieder im militärische
Fähigkeiten investieren und deswegen
braucht es auch mehr als die 100
Milliarden eine aufschlagstockung des
verteidigungsetats sonst wird es nicht
funktioniert fast 30 Milliarden Euro des
Sondervermögens sein inzwischen
vertraglich gebunden so Pistorius auch
die Panzerhaubitzen die an die Ukraine
gingen sollen schnell ersetzt werden der
falsche Weg findet die Linke ein Jahr
Zeitenwende geht in eine völlig falsche
Richtung globales Wettrüsten macht uns
nicht sicherer wir brauchen eher den
Blick dahin wie kann man viele
Konfliktlösungen wieder stärken in der
Ampel bahnt sich derweil Streitern wie
viel mehr kriegt die Bundeswehr und wie
viel bleibt im Haushalt für die anderen
koalitionsprojekte deshalb
darf die äußere Sicherheit nicht gegen
den inneren Zusammenhalt die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit nicht gegen den
Kampf gegen Kinderarmut ausgespielt
werden die Abhängigkeit von russischen
Hülle und Gas die konnte die Zeiten wenn
die verringern unter anderem mit
flüssiggast Terminals schnell errichtet
aber nicht schnell genug findet die
Union es geht um
Energieversorgungssicherheit und es geht
auch um Bezahlbarkeit von Energie und da
hören und sehen wir von der
Bundesregierung viel zu wenig ein Jahr
nach der Zeiten wenn der Rede vom
Kanzler Scholz wird langsam sichtbar wie
sehr nicht nur die Welt eine andere ist
sondern auch das Land
zeitenwände ist ein großes Wort jakuta
la benedy hat die Bundesregierung denn
umgesetzt was sie angekündigt hat wir
haben das zu bewerten lohnt es sich noch
mal in die Rede von Olaf Scholz zu
schauen und zu gucken was er sich denn
selbst vorgenommen hat nämlich neben mir
Geld für die Bundeswehr und die Nato hat
er damals noch vier weitere
Handlungsaufträge für seine
Bundesregierung formuliert da stand ganz
oben die Ukraine zu unterstützen und
Russland mit Sanktionen unter Druck zu
setzen aber auch die Energieversorgung
zu sichern und die diplomatischen Kanäle
offen zu halten auf all diesen Feldern
hat die Bundesregierung tatsächlich
gehandelt Teils der kritisch begleitet
von der Opposition teils auch
konstruktiv begleitet von der Opposition
und zum Teil sogar erfolgreicher als sie
selber gedacht hat nämlich bei der
Sicherung der Energieversorgung aber
alle diese Felder sind auch offene
Baustellen so zu sagen denn zum einen
sind sie während der Krise nicht
abzuschließen und zum anderen hängt eben
alles davon ab wie sich der Krieg weiter
fort entwickelt gerade für die
Energiesicherheit gilt es wir wissen ja
noch nicht wie der nächste Winter wird
da die Versorgungslage ist und so wird
vieles am Ende darauf ankommen ob die
Bundesregierung jetzt dran bleibt und
wie entschieden sie dran bleibt an der
Erreichung dieser selbstgesetzten Ziele
und wie viel Sie möglicherweise dann
auch eben im Streit um andere
koalitionsprojekte bereit ist wieder
nach hinten zu stellen danke für diese
Einschätzung
ja und ein Jahr nach der Zeitenwende
Rede vom Bundeskanzler Scholz was hat
sich seitdem verändert von Bundeswehr
bis Schulden im Internet haben wir ein
Analyse für Sie in Wort und Bild
jederzeit in unserer ZDF heute App
der Schutz der Menschenrechte und
nukleare Abrüstung für beides hat sich
Außenministerin bärburg heute stark
gemacht vor den Vereinten Nationen Genf
forderte sie weitere Untersuchungen zu
den russischen Kriegsverbrechen in der
Ukraine die Gemeinschaft müsse um
Gerechtigkeit für jedes Opfer kämpfen
in einer zweiten Rede rief bärburg
Präsident Putin zur Rückkehr zum
atomwaffenkontrollvertrag new start auf
in Genf hat heute auch eine
geber-konferenz für den jemenstand
Deutschland hat für das laufende Jahr
120 Millionen Euro für das
Bürgerkriegsland zugesagt insgesamt kam
1,1 Milliarden Euro für die Hungernden
im Jemen zusammen nötig wäre nach
unangaben etwa das Vierfache gewesen
denn im Jemen brauchen 21 Millionen
Menschen Hilfe Nahrung Trinkwasser
medizinische Versorgung das sind zwei
Drittel der Bevölkerung zurzeit gibt es
eine brüchige Waffenruhe zwischen den
Regierungstruppen und den Husten
der Tarif Streit im öffentlichen Dienst
ist festgefahren Arbeitgeber und
Arbeitnehmervertreter liegen noch weit
auseinander auf dem Tisch lag dieses
Angebot 5% mehr Geld in zwei Schritten
eine Einmalzahlung von 2.500 Euro und
ein höheres Weihnachtsgeld eine
Frechheit sagt Verdi und bleibt bei der
Kernforderung von 10,5 Prozent aber
mindestens 500 Euro mehr pro Monat die
Devise der Gewerkschaften jetzt den
Druck verstärken heißt neue Warnstreiks
Ariane Güdel
lautstark fordern Sie mehr Geld
Angestellte und Beamte im öffentlichen
Dienst in Kitas Ämtern im Nahverkehr in
der Luftsicherheit bundesweit in Köln
heute Morgen mit einem Protestmarsch die
Mitarbeiter der Flughafenfeuerwehr in
Düsseldorf legen ihre Arbeit nieder die
Gewerkschaften kommen bei und Verdi
haben nicht nur hier sondern auch am
Flughafen Köln-Bonn zum Streik
aufgerufen hunderte Flüge fallen aus
Lage ist dass wir ein unglaublich hohe
Inflation haben dass Energiekosten
gestiegen sind das einfach die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ihre
Lebenshaltungskosten weiterhin
bestreiten können deshalb fordern sie
10,5 % mehr Lohn und mindestens 500 €
mehr was vor allem für die unteren
Einkommen wichtig sein die meisten
Passagiere waren vorgewarnt die anderen
hoffen dass ihr Flug doch abhebt viele
zeigen Verständnis
mit den Streikenden da fühle ich mit und
hoffentlich kriegen sie wenigsten acht
Prozent zehn Prozent ist schon eine
Ansage mit fünfeinhalb oder was pro Jahr
wäre das schon okay am Himmel blieb es
ruhiger aber auch auf Straßen und
Schienen vor allem in NRW gähnende Lehre
in Köln die Arbeitgeber bieten bisher
einmalig 2500 Euro und eine geringere
Lohnsteigerung unakzeptabel so die
Streitenden
oder nicht signalisieren dass da was
besseres kommt dann werden sich die
Streiks noch aushalten morgen gibt es
neue Streiks dann auch in Niedersachsen
fortsetzung folgt
[Applaus]
drei Wochen nach dem schweren Erdbeben
hat der Boden in der Türkei erneut
gezittert erste Berichte sprechen von
dutzenden Verletzten gleichzeitig wächst
die Kritik am Krisenmanagement von
Präsident Erdogan bei einem Fußballspiel
forderten tausende lautstark seinen
Rücktritt aus Solidarität mit den
Erdbeben Opfern warfen die zuschauenden
im Stadion von Besiktas Istanbul
Plüschtiere und Kinderspielsachen auf
den Rasen die will der Verein nun an die
Kinder im Katastrophengebiet liefern
bleiben wir bei den jüngsten Opfern
dieser Katastrophe alleine in der Türkei
sind 4,6 Millionen Kinder vom Erdbeben
betroffen sagt UNICEF
einige haben ihre Eltern oder
Geschwister verloren oft weiß man ihre
Namen nicht und kann sie nicht zuordnen
selten stellt noch das Zuhause genauso
wenig wie die Schule oder die Kita viele
Kinder sind traumatisiert wie man sich
jetzt um sie kümmert hat eine Brille in
Iskenderun beobachtet
Musik und Kinder lachen an einem Ort der
für so viel Leid und Zerstörung steht
in der Zeltstadt für die Überlebenden
von esken darum kümmern sich freiwillige
auch um die Kinder sie alle haben
Schreckliches erlebt
schon
es war sehr schlimm ich habe große Angst
gehabt an meinem Bett stand ein Schrank
der ist auf meine Mutter und meinem
Vater gefallen
meine Eltern kamen aus dem Schlafzimmer
und haben uns umarmt wir haben uns dann
im Badezimmer versteckt
3000 Menschen leben in der Zeltstadt
viele von ihnen sind Kinder
ihr Leben hat sich von einem auf den
anderen Tag verändert sie haben
Verwandte Freunde verloren Traumata die
sich hier mit Psychologen besprechen
können
einem vierjährigen fünfjährigen Kind ist
nicht klar was überhaupt passiert ist
und wir versuchen Ihnen das durch Spiele
klar zu machen das ist eine Katastrophe
war
im Bücherbus treffen wir Eileen und
ihren Bruder Schule gibt es für die
Kinder von Iskenderun gerade nicht
obwohl ich mich mit meiner Lehrerin
nicht gut verstanden habe vermisse ich
sogar sie jetzt sehr
zusammen lachen spielen wenigstens das
wollen Sie hier den Kindern ermöglichen
und den Menschen helfen können Sie mit
Spenden ans Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe IBAN
de6500 Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben Türkei
Syrien nachzulesen auf
spenden.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
es gibt zahlreiche Lebensmittel für
Kinder mit viel Zucker Salz oder Fett
und dafür soll nicht mehr so leicht bei
Kindern geworben werden können wenn es
nach ernährungsminister mehr geht das
Ziel Kinder sollen gesünder aufwachsen
so sollen zum Beispiel 100 Meter um
Schulen Kitas und Spielplätze keine
Werbeplakate mehr hängen dürfen für
ungesunde Lebensmittel für Kinder Ritter
Buchholz berichtet
ob online im Radio oder Fernsehen solche
Werbung könnte bald weitgehen verboten
sein am Pranger alle Produkte die
gezielt Kinder ansprechen und zu viel
Zucker Salz oder Fett beinhalten der
ernährungsminister will Kinder künftig
besser schützen gesetzlichen Regelungen
werden immer da nötig wo freiwillige
Selbstverpflichtungen scheitern fakt ist
die bisherigen freiwilligen
Selbstverpflichtungen haben bei Schutz
der Kinder nachweislich versagt Kinder
und jugendärzte loben den Vorschlag der
mittlerweile gilt fast jedes fünfte Kind
als zu dick schuld sind Bewegungsmangel
und falscher Ernährung manche sehen
dafür die Verantwortung bei den Eltern
andere anderswo
sind ein Meilenstein im Kampf gegen
federnierungen Übergewicht er nimmt
endlich die Lebensmittelindustrie in
eine Pflicht also macht Schluss mit dem
Prinzip der Freiwilligkeit dass die
Bundesregierung jahrelang vorgelebt hat
die Werbewirtschaft nennt die Vorgaben
drastisch sie würden nicht zu weniger
übergewichtigen Kindern führen
stattdessen
wenn ein solches generelles Werbeverbot
für Lebensmittel umgesetzt würde dann
wird das natürlich massiv auf die
Refinanzierung von Medien Refinanzierung
von Sport es war auch die Rede von
Sponsoring
beim bei der heutigen Pressekonferenz
wird das Massiv dort eingreifen und zu
erheblichen Nachteilen führen der
Minister selbst rechnet mit Widerstand
die FDP hält nichts von generellen
verboten die Union kritisiert staatliche
Bevormundung nun soll der Entwurf
abgestimmt werden
jetzt kommen wir zum Sport und ja sehr
überzeugen in Bayern Katja ja der FC
Bayern München grüßt nach einem kurzen
Intermezzo das BVB wieder von der
Bundesliga Tabellenspitze nach einem
vollkommen verdienten 3:0 gestern Abend
im Topspiel ging Verfolger Union Berlin
entspannte Bayern Angriff der Berliner
abgewehrtabellenführung von Dortmund
zurückerkämpft eine sportliche
Machtdemonstration 31 Minute Eric Maxim
choupo-mutting Klasse Timing die Führung
1 zu 0 command erhöhte 9 Minuten danach
in typischer Art auf 2:0 und
Geburtstagskind Jamal muss Jana nach
Vorarbeit von Müller mit der
Entscheidung noch vor der Pause
wir haben ja wenn ich eine gute
Spielfreude gehabt das ist schon ein
Schlüssel den ich immer wieder sehen
will dass man alles vielmals Siegen
liebt uns verlieren hast ne
verdienen besser
ihre der Sieg der Bayern verdient aber
Union hat den Kopf weiter oben die Liga
ist längst noch nicht entschieden
Südkorea bekommt einen neuen
Fußball-Nationaltrainer Jürgen Klinsmann
Klinsmann erhält zunächst ein
Dreijahresvertrag und soll Südkorea zur
WM 2026 führen zuletzt war der
58-Jährige vor drei Jahren Trainer bei
Hertha BSC verließ den Verein auf
eigenen Wunsch hin allerdings nach drei
Monaten wieder ja heute ist Ruhetag bei
der Nordischen Ski-WM in Planitzer
Slowenien Zeit also für ein
Zwischenfazit und das fällt aus
deutscher Sicht positiv aus acht
Medaillen sammelte das DSV-Team bislang
drei davon Gold und an allen war
skispringerin Katharina Althaus
beteiligt sie ist schon jetzt die
goldkönigin und es könnte noch besser
werden Katharina Althaus flog über sich
selbst und alle anderen hinaus zu
dreimal Gold von der Normalschanze im
einzelteam und gestern auch im
mixspringen mit ihrem zweiten Sprung auf
102 Meter brachte sie Deutschland in
Führung Andreas Wellinger musste Gold
nur noch sichern ihr Jubel über das
dritte Gold war mitreißend und im Team
noch schöner
Gold holen als Team für die Cutter auch
für die anderen Athletinnen ist kann man
gar nicht so richtig beschreiben wie wie
extrem gut das jetzt gelaufen ist
Althaus in Topform könnte
am mit Großschanze großes gelingen
viermal Gold bei einer einzigen WM
konnte im Skispringen noch niemand
gewinnen
das wäre da was morgen aber erstmal lang
läuft der Frauen sehr schön danke Katja
gestern Nacht gab es in vielen Teilen
von Deutschland wundersames zu bestaunen
und zwar Polarlichter schöner Schein
hoch über Niedersachsen und anderswo
etwa an der niederländischen Küste
üblich ist das Leuchten eigentlich nur
in nördlichsten breiten jetzt aber haben
Sonnenstürme elektrisch geladene
Teilchen zu uns geschickt und die
zaubern die satten Farben ans Firmament
wohl auch kommende Nacht zu sehen
vielleicht auch am Himmel über ihn
ob und wenn wo sie die Polarlichter
vielleicht auch in der kommenden Nacht
sehen können das erfahren Sie gleich von
Katja horneffer Dunja Hayali begrüßte
zum heute-journal um 21 Uhr auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend kurz vor seinem Ende will
uns der meteorologische Winter nochmal
zeigen wie das mit der Kälte geht das
sehen Sie hier in dieser Strömung aus
Nordost sie sehen auch die typische
kaltluftbewölkung über Deutschland vor
allen Dingen aber auch über dem Atlantik
für viele gab es aber heute auch
strahlende Sonnenschein wie z.B auch in
Paris ist viel ein bisschen Schnee noch
im Erzgebirge und auch am Alpenrand und
auch jetzt in der Nacht sind letzte
Schneeschauer auf der Schwäbischen Alb
oder auch im Schwarzwald nicht ganz
ausgeschlossen sonst ist es häufig klar
und wenn sie noch mal nach Polarlichtern
schauen wollen dass ich der
Mittelgebirge könnte das klappen nur
nicht direkt hier an den Küsten von Nord
und Ostsee da sind Nebel Dunst und
Wolkenfelder wohl zu dicht ich darüber
wollten gibt's auch im Osten und die
Temperaturen singen auf plus zwei bis
minus 11 Grad am kältesten wird am
alpenrad und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 0 Grad jetzt
zum Beispiel im Vogtland und 7 Grad am
Mittel unterm rein sowie auch in
Nordfriesland und ähnlich wie heute gibt
es auch morgen viel Sonnenschein und am
Nachmittag dann einige Quellwolken bei
Nordostwind und auch der meteorologische
frühlinger Mittwoch und Donnerstag wird
ganz ähnlich starten am Freitag dreht
der Winter bis bald